back up my broccolini get your life
together
Happy Valentines uh happy Valentine's
Day bro I'm Valentine's Day bro
so why you dressed like that dressed
like a why this hat on this is like kind
of a balance I thought this would be
like a Valentine's Day hat and oh yeah
you don't think so
mmm not really doesn't give off that
vibe you don't think so it's like a red
vibe I feel like it
well it's red so I guess that's
Valentine's Day yeah Valentine's you
know Elmer Fudd's gay sister well I mean
no Valentines dude I'm not thinking when
I put on when I put this on this morning
I'm not thinking I want to dress up like
a Elmer Fudd you don't or an offspring
of his no I'm thinking what do I have
that's red I'm in a hurry
that's fair you know Happy Valentines me
too man thanks for really you look like
a UH twink that's what you seem like a
twink I'd be a giant twink yeah he said
like the giant twink of Hollywood you
like the rare giant twink
you look like West Hollywood like Asian
alee like occasionally he'll peek out
from behind an eight ball at a group
meet up you know at a late-night group
meet up for men and unique men you look
you look like you have a rich sugar
daddy then once you address like a
hunter green warm about Vin you look
like a substitute teacher doesn't know
what the [ __ ] he's doing that's what you
look like
dude this is 50% silk this outfit it's
nice man I'm not hating on it really no
no you heard the beginning of any of the
show this hat is for Valentine's happy
Valentine's Day I love you guys yeah all
the hunters out there ah let's do this
my man how we kicking this off read my
drift rip my drip look girl and leave it
up a little different this week instead
of a listener submitting themselves we
got some some celebrities that were
tripping oh oh snap a first up cardi B
at the Grammys Wow
that and this has a very was aggressive
it looks yeah it has that Andy Dufresne
like I just you know they said it would
take a man forty years to get out of
this here address what car TB did it in
less than seven months
it's like Andy Warhol you know I'm
saying like just busted out of the top
of it I've you know how I feel I feel
how her man looks right there he is so
disappointed well he should be
disappointed first of all the man is
named upset what's his name offset
offset offset
yeah well he's uh he looks upset first
of all and he should be upset because
he's been I know it like this man has
been really almost stalking this girl
it's like she sees I feel like he's a
little bit of a star like he's just
always honor yeah he's way too close
they're like hey bro get out the shot at
me go it's her moment
yeah and he's just all he's chasing her
really hard man he seems kind of like a
lonely dude that grew his hair out and
looks cool and also he's starting to get
like I feel like I'm starting to fall
out a little bit like he's part of the
me goes there's a big band right but
he's starting to become this weird dude
that's just following her around the
country I like Kelly Rowland yeah he's
got that Kelly Rowland and then he's
almost see that's the thing they got the
Beyonce then you go into Kelly Rowland
territory you don't want that and then
you go into Michelle way to Michelle the
third one nobody even knows who that is
and he's right now he's in Kelly Rowland
territory you know who knows who
Michelle is Jesus yeah she seems gospel
that's what she did she went I Beyonce
gots the ass can't do that Kelly
Rowland's whatever I'm gonna go gospel
yeah that's what she's doing and she's
back with the lower men and that's a
good place to be but that's where this
man is headed I mean he'll be in two
weeks
who'da we're off set could be singing at
him he could be at you know when any
Martin Luther King jr. Boulevard in any
city near you or after The Undertaker's
looking for a handler that's what he
looks like you're in the Undertaker's
guy on there yeah that's what he gives
me a Paul beare vibe he look like a guy
that likes Lang's like bootleg licorice
outside of like an event you know what
I'm saying like he's got those low-key
vines on the DL Sun he looks like he's
selling you he looks like the guys that
sell CDs at Venice Beach
albums you don't want see you the new
easy album yeah
see deez nutz Brennan that's a porn in
its time about him it's about his
frickin wife that is his wife looking
like a goddamn live-action Little
Mermaid figure it's only his wife I'm
like if she logs into the website for an
hour that says hey I'm your wife right
now like it seems like he kind of gets
he gets kind of used by this lady and
this lady is cardi B and she's really
you know she's kind of like the new
Jennifer Lopez she's kind of like the
kind of chubby ariana grande E and she
looks if you can see this outfit you
have to see this say I never this isn't
really a outfit this looks like a
fallopian tube that the plumbing went
bad on yeah it looks like it looks like
a firecracker that looks like someone
held a firecracker in their hand and she
came out and exploded yeah I mean if you
it looks like she's like in an oyster
and then she's like not a pearl you know
but like actually she has pearls on
maybe this whole thing is like I'm an
oyster - I'm telling you this is a
little mermaid vibe like some of us are
a little mermaid this look like
Salmonella the musical dude look at this
this looks like a hysterectomy who hit
the highway she looks like a hemorrhoid
- did you burst out of a hemorrhoid yeah
Suze you ever had a hemorrhoid
I've had one did I had one where was it
I had one I think on my back like on my
visit but I'm talking about a hemorrhoid
in your ass bro oh no that's right I
don't do anything like that oh you
shouldn't well that's what she looks
like though and I got you that itchy who
got me that the Lord really yeah for
being just too big and strong got it put
a hemorrhoid your ass you out of your
mind
dude I didn't put it there came in but
yes you have a wild unique look I think
a very you know it took her 17 days to
get out of this thing I don't know if
this is an outfit or if she's being
engulfed by something um this definitely
has a look of like an endangered species
kind of look but also it looks like this
dress you could just like drawstring it
up the top and just sleep in there yeah
it does look like a giant sleeping bag a
little bit huh yeah it's like a sleeping
bag but it's like a sleepwalking bag
it's like you could also walk around in
it and just go back to sleep yeah it's
some bull
it looks like you let's move on but
upset looking upset right there dog keen
doing he looks like he's his entire life
right yeah I'm regretting looking at
this don't press it after I press it
knows won't know it's in to press it
wouldn't you not like better what else
we got next up for rip my drip at a
recent fight
we got Floyd Mayweather god damn it what
the [ __ ] is he wearing
wow so much it just sometimes I see
these busted ass boots what why did he
look racist bro and I'm not racist dude
I mean that gives off that I am or not
what have you heard you know off that
hunting racist vibe
yeah it looks medium-rare doesn't even
take that jacket is off fully cooked he
looks like he's duck hunting in the
nightclubs little buddy there little
shotgun shell Steve Harvey this dude his
handler that's the president of
Mayweather freaking promotions that guy
that hit will steal your money that's
what he looks like
he looked he looks like he has a he
drives a Cadillac and will sell your
guns out the back that's what he looks
good he look he look like
that guy has a very he looks like TD
jakes a little bit like that pastor like
TD Ameritrade Jakes he looks like a bad
banker he looks like a dude that sells
mutual funds out of a out of a Cadillac
he looks like yo he looks like a bank
robber and a cartoon that's good looks
like he look like Steve har dude he
looks like Steve hardly have you seen Oh
Steve hardly let me tell you is it looks
like he's reaching for money right yeah
that's what he's doing is he bluffing
dude it looks like some people dress
like they're blind you know and that's
like a new thing to do I think did you
give them attention a lot of Danish
people you'll see it sometimes even the
Middle East Persia Israel you see a lot
of guys dress I'm like kind of a blind
kind of look he looks like type of do
they sell you a [ __ ] Scientology book
out of his Cadillac out of an old old
man it's autograph to buy like buy him
know things by Barry Sanders or by like
Eric Dickerson it's
by Mike Tyson silly guy could get dude
they said of this black guy would come
to our town he would sell everything was
autographed by Eric Dickerson it could
be anything a blender a bowl a woman's
pot I swear this guy had kidnapped Eric
Dickerson I was just making him sign
stuff do we have like a hairdryer signed
by Eric Dickerson this dude looks like
he'll show you a riddick bowe sandal
yeah man I think but look at Floyd dude
come on that jacket looks high in iron
it looks like that looks like a heavy
Flo coat that he's wearing do you know
what I'm saying he got very it looks
hella messy don't you match though you
got the purple boots with the maroon top
we made he pays someone to dress on my
head he doesn't realize that the rest of
the world doesn't look like this do I
don't know the the the gang jockeys in
yeah just dressed like that tonight and
all ooh yeah those look like they're
made out of fruit roll-ups bro yeah it
looks like you by the foot dude
literally brought literally by the foot
maid boots yeah I bet that's what it is
actually
imagine if he has a basement with a
couple of little fellas down there
strong women just beaten just beaten
together little sheets of fruit by the
foot so we eat him off and when he gets
home cuz he has a here's a brothel
chicks yeah ten of oh yeah Wow well
dinner's ready ladies eat on up fruit by
the foot guns nuts in your mouth what
else we got all right it's time for King
at our sting it first up we got a couple
of fellows what's up boys Evan Hayden
from Tallahassee Florida believe it or
not I'm actually not his father
we're identical twins but we got a king
of stinging for you so King and her
sting it when twins try to look exactly
alike uh sting night yeah [ __ ] that
noise be your own first let me know dude
they couldn't look more up then also
[Laughter]
twins in what world they do not look
like twins yeah are you sure I feel like
and look it seemed like you guys are
nice guys it seemed like you guys both
might be trapped in the same vehicle at
the same time you should together yeah
you're together so together doesn't mean
you're twins you have to be too what you
got to look like you come from the same
mother I think they're confused just
because you guys hang out a lot it
doesn't make you twins maybe these days
it does man and maybe that's this new
culture you know but who thing you know
a new pronoun twins that dress the same
Oh
basically that's Stockholm Syndrome I
think is what you're talking to get your
own identity bro yeah dude no one likes
to of anybody yeah I mean I hate imagine
to feels I dressed like this exhausting
dude I would kill the other one if I had
any respect for myself and I'm gonna say
this I must give me twenty seconds to
burn I'm gonna say this to twins out
there and people that are you know
cutting their faces open to look like
each other doing stuff like that
Kardashians
yes if you have a twin or somebody that
looks just like you and you let them run
around live in doing stuff ruining your
name making love to people around town
and doing stuff like that stealing then
you are part of the problem okay if I
had somebody look just like me who's
running around town doing dice and doing
cocaine and stuff like that I would do
what I need to do to make sure that
they're not here anymore and eliminate
them let me get into this what I would
do is at the age of eight I'd put a
sword in the backyard and you guys got a
battle out yeah there's only room on
this world for one of you yeah it's that
but that's what the Spartans did really
yeah I think so yeah so get Spartan quit
babysitting half of you like some little
[ __ ] monkey and do something special for
yourself or run run into each other and
be become one yes like run your heads
into each other and just kind of yeah
dude now some of those twins you get the
ones that have the uh that gridlock
going on you now talk about the traffic
jam of the brain yeah
rain jam and I like that [ __ ] man you
ever seen they have a some YouTube video
you ready to give it those fellas some
markers and they draw like a I mean they
draw a beautiful stuff and you can flick
one in the hand the other fields well
you got double the brain - and if they
juggle it's easy for them to juggle
because there's just three balls near in
that four it's basically the same as
hand in balls in a circle still
technically counts yeah they're stuck
together but twins fight to the death I
mean God puts you out here obviously to
figure it out not to just meander around
each other no there can only be one yeah
yeah there can only be one but I love
the idea of running fast each other and
see what happens yeah we thought the
movies running together
let's see portal to another world opens
up yeah I love that
all right next up for King understand we
have Lisa
all right bee sting Rat King what do you
think about older women with younger men
King interesting it well we know what
you think we know what you think first
of all you seemed like a sweet woman
said eyebrows on you yeah you got two
eyebrows but you drew on yeah and you
drew well very well I like him I
actually like I met this lady before I'm
sure you have but I'll say this she
seems like I mean first of all this lady
looks like she is in a rolls-royce or
something sitting in like a fancy car
with that small back window like yeah a
Great Gatsby yeah she's in a Bentley in
a [ __ ] meat coat and she's trying do
you think of young dudes he's trying to
get Bentley to over by a couple of
[ __ ] sophomores yeah a couple
sophomore boys in high school let the
boys run that high school train the
thing is is I'm all about it man if
you're a young struggling actor comedian
you go with the older lady don'ts take
care of your bills let me drive though
the Bentley around five yeah man it's
like a sponsor yeah but some people go
to college
nah you just get an old lady and she
sponsors all your [ __ ] oh well you got
to put in work and my putting work you
have to dig down that old lady oh it's
gonna have to get hairy here and there
man they wake up super early you a drink
prune juice and [ __ ] yeah drink pop off
at the [ __ ] back country club and the
bank yeah got a run into Walmart all the
goddamn time you have to wait in the car
while she's in there you run errands all
the [ __ ] time she forgets her stuff
has to run back in the house yeah dude
it's gonna be you have to run out in the
yard and do yo just you're not have to
do work in the RV and go out in the yard
and sweat a little new t-shirt all the
time yeah all the time
see that I mean that's a lot of work not
you say that man someone's gonna cooler
but that when you start going through
all the [ __ ] you got to do for these
hoes and then you know you're the sex is
scheduled yeah like it's not spontaneous
you know at 6:00 p.m. you gotta get your
dick out yeah it's not like you just get
to catch you know maybe something
romantic comes on TV and you guys vibe
during its no Netflix and chill [ __ ] no
golden crown and suck this yeah that's
how that goes down graham crackers and
he jagged me all look as soon as she
gets done it and whatever she's bitten
it's time for you to start noting
wherever your nut my brother you know is
wrong with you matter touch I'm sorry
it's too hard I'll say this man a lot of
these young buckos are getting
approached by teachers and stuff like
that now and I think a lot I think
because a lot of women and Nick is even
mentioned as poor in our podcast that a
lot of these women the only place they
still see men being men are these young
guys where they can still like you know
do athletics and like they're sweating
and it's okay and they're not like being
convicted of any crimes yes so men are
still the saddest thing is it like a lot
of these boys seem like men to them sure
and so that's why these old ladies are
really hitting my mom sure and there's
nothing wrong with [ __ ] a teacher to
get in there I don't have a problem with
that it's like either passed the test
and put in time there or you titty [ __ ]
your English team yeah look bro I blew
so many bones to my English teacher all
my teachers reach brawl I had miss
famalaro in fourth grade I'm nice still
bust nuts really not a lady named Miss
shut up to the Virginia Court Tigers we
a Delaney miss fart PHA Artie right when
I was in my fourth grade
and nobody liked her but I remember a
little bit later on in school we had
this lady named Jeanne Garofalo bruh
I mean I mean tits from just outer space
tits you know and they should allow them
to work in the schools because know
about my learning about half my blood is
about wow you can't understand a word
you're saying cuz your [ __ ] tips on
my face lady I got I got a de yeah I got
a D cuz my dick is gonna explode
get your [ __ ] I'm sorry this Hooters
dude where's this Virginia core
elementary to the toilet show me what
where's my [ __ ] way how long were you
in elementary school I think nine years
nine years I was in nine years it's
great time while well you know there's
only three grades brother oh wow so
there's a lot bro they trick those
teachers and you get their tits out of
my face is what I'm saying let me learn
about history and English yeah not about
my rock-hard dick dude all I all I knew
was the history of straight tits oh dude
yeah that's hot knew the history of blue
balls dude I remember man I'd be so like
they had um this one teacher she was so
hot whenever the movies would play we
would crawl around on the floor and try
to get her hair even his pieces of her I
hear you dude we had one teacher named
mrs. roach oh yeah well this didn't get
dark she had cancer of the face and it
took her eyes and nose but she just wore
an eye patch then brought the nose out
like everything was all good but this
thing was go she and kind of wet is a
hole and then she's already talking
about the last episode of King in this
thing you would think and she would get
up there and just [ __ ] educate us on
social studies I'm like damn I bet you
got a hole in your face yeah had big
tits though did she
big tits man you know what I think well
you think they could have you know kind
of spooned out one of them breasts and
filled in that ah space you know you'd
think she'd have been you know a little
bit more titty for her nose she'd have
been able to compartmentalize things
better yeah that's a good idea I'll say
this man if you were a young fella and
there's items opportunities with older
women and I never did good with them you
know I remember this one lady tried to
get me to touch her crotch and
everything on a trampoline out there
Mississippi one night and I got scared
and there was a bunch of like I don't
know if there was wasps it wasn't wasps
it was like locusts or or not to know
loke
okay and they had locusts out there and
everybody and it was scary and so you
know you go through stuff like that
where you can't you know get it up and
you're on a trampoline it's embarrassing
and then I could then this woman made me
fun comfortable and she was built like a
little man dude the nerve she was built
like a second baseman you know a
shortstop the problem is she had a short
haircut mm yeah so he says it's uh the
other thing is you tell you wait you
mean you [ __ ] Wade Boggs um so but
also these older chicks are into things
you're not into I'm trying to watch
Netflix maybe Punisher maybe stranger
things
maybe Game of Thrones they're into the
Golden Girls learn to reruns of [ __ ]
friends that's not my thing man well I
like Reba and I think as long as she and
I can meet there then I could I could
spend some time with an order lady I
just as long as it as long as so you
shut your mouth they're not super chatty
I can see you there you shot your money
show you another shout-out to old chicks
all right next up last one for Cain our
sting it this week it's for King it we
didn't say you did we [ __ ] King young
dudes hooking up with all the chicks
unless you're trying to learn unless
you're in and then get your tits out of
my face that should not be in the
classroom and that's for those male
teachers get your dick out of my face I
don't wear those tight pants those
stupid khakis and then have your [ __ ]
three-piece set in my face we had a guy
who had pictures of his dick on the
outside of his shorts it was like they
were first of all they were really short
and then at pictures of his dick all
over I'm trying like I'm trying to learn
calculus and you got your [ __ ] dick
in my face farik oculus bro and you
should have figured that one out
yourself you're right but I'll say this
is that if they have here's one safe
thing these days is that an older woman
you're gonna be else you're not gonna
meet to you she's not gonna you know
there's gonna be no bones about it
no dm's no catfish yeah no bones about
it you're gonna have a shot so I think
that if you want to practice some sex
and get some sexual abilities and do
some real sex you can do it like that
get some experience under your belt yeah
King it all right last one for King
understand it we got from Alexander hey
what's up hey what's up Brennan Rat King
bee sting gang gang gang baby I'm Alex
I'm stationed down here in Camp
Pendleton California I'm from Wisconsin
born and raised homo beer just a cheese
in the Badgers go pack so I got
something for you guys wearing your
drawers two days in a row
qinger Steen lot goes into this brother
let me ask him when he showed his
drawers - yeah he did uh depends on the
color depends what you do for work okay
well they're dark
you know I rock him - three days in a
row mm-hmm you know I don't know how big
I don't wanna judge me in here but if
they're a dark color Dundee you can rock
them two days in a row
sure he might get pee pee stains on the
front no one can see him some minor will
be camouflage I might have streaks out
the back you can't see him yeah you know
I'm saying nothing you a little stinky
oh you a little stinky and I think they
get a little hot that's one thing I
notice about a hum that undercarriage
you know one thing I noticed about
underwears is awesome they get hot you
notice that yeah you've had them on for
a couple days they get a little bit hot
yeah they get like up there - like I
wear straight-up undies like undie
undies what do you wear boxers
what do you mean on I wear briefs bro
I'll get [ __ ] your dad's briefs yeah
I want to keep it old-school bro I keep
it well over that Calvin Klein I keep it
a long school you see my kind of guy you
everything with that short a skeg bro
yeah I bet you go free - really looks
like he took me a Panera Gonzo's robbing
a bank in my underwear Oh somebody
somebody use a mask on somebody drew me
a picture of your dick it took them like
two seconds to draw oh really well they
can't really yeah or you had bad Wi-Fi
coming through yeah you do you wear your
in the baggy boxers yeah get these
afraid are you in I guess yes obviously
I wear briefs dude and I have to get the
ones with the extended cab in the front
for this cop dude you know what I'm
saying like wat don't [ __ ] touch me
takes down about that quad cab in the
front well here's the problem is you
build up that warm
that warm air between your nuts and your
legs and neck it starts to get so warm
it starts to almost create its own
weather system and it gets you get a
little bit of like rain that kind of
it's just built into your time that dick
rain yeah tropical dick rain yeah but
also when you were underwear in multiple
days in a row my [ __ ] starts to sag so
see a little baggy in the front in the
back wait you're like it breaks down
your underwear the underwear breaks down
like you're kind of like it's holding
its old potato yeah it's like your
grandma's neck after about three days
yes yeah girl one that have like nut
meat internet you over the girl that
chapters of different books on nut
necking ttan grandma nothing to she had
the best nut neck yeah pulling your nut
girl the longer you go with dirty undies
are repeat on these are are use they
call them you start running the risk of
losing that it's transversal with the
way you might lose the ability of
possibility you're gonna do sex with
somebody yeah but also you start to
stink you know I think is like right now
you smell it you smell there down right
now I took a shower this morning
- you don't smell anything it's gonna be
a little cheesy a little brilliant
cheddar cheese okay a sharp cheddar like
a sharp cheddar oh now you're talking
well I will say this then that you get
that you could once you start not
wearing underwear there's this cheese
chart that kind of factors up so the
first day yes pretty good [ __ ] our baby
you got that Oh daddy sharp but he's
still here a ski you know and then the
second day it kind of goes away and it
just disappears who knows and you're
like oh man what is else that's the Lord
that's the Lord now if you keep riding I
start dancing with the devil then you
get that grilled cheese that Thursday
talk about that government grilled
cheese yeah GGC bro yeah it's it seems
taste you put it all so it doesn't you
know it's kind of weak in your throat
and you can also smell it through your
jeans yeah and then sit down a gust of
wind comes up like that's not good yeah
and they're talking to a young lady
that's you know another day goes by
you got that crumbled blue cheese oh you
came from blue you got that Ghouta too
a lot of people get that Ghouta and then
the next day you hit on their that uh
worse what is the some of that goat
cheese buy these eggs goats goat cheese
huh
dododo you ever spelled goat cheese I
eat it I've never smelled it yeah I
don't smell it
really yeah it's day six you're MB so
you get that goat so you hit that cheese
chart with them on DS c32 yeah are you
coming in with that American Chetty
coming in you know that grilled that
Ghouta that loose burger whatever they
got Lloris to start that Tillamook bruh
and that's when you have an infection
you know if you get that Tillamook you
have an infection yeah you know it you
know it
oh you know it you know it you know it
um yes but yeah underwear I think it's
fair to say man you you two days in a
row can understand as long as dark
underwear King it if it's white
underwear bad idea don't do it
unconfident lee if you stay confident
your head and look people in the eyes
while you do it then I'll respect that
but if you're looking the other way and
ducking people and wearing sunglasses
and doing it then I don't respect that
so it's a little bit based on who you
are but I king alright that does it for
King intersting it this week in honor of
Valentine's Day but it may be a
permanent segment we're gonna give some
fellas some relationship advice my hat
hurts man
is it too hot yeah just gonna be colder
in here mmm well you can take it off bro
you here let's exactly the same way they
have that on or not they look good yeah
you look like the lead singer of the Goo
Goo Dolls after a seven day bender yeah
well I'm going back I just want to come
into the city anymore cuz I've run into
people like okay judgmental creep let's
do IV ously been stealing clothes from
children alright so the first first
young man who needs help is is Connor
they all need help I thought it seemed
Conor McGregor with his coat pie I
didn't see you there hey what's up boys
the Oh Brendon how's it going so Bronner
can
Salt Lake City Utah beautiful and
liberal gang gang bro gasps I had a
question in regards to a female so I'm
seeing this get out
and she is in au-pair which is like a
live-in nanny that rich family in
Richmond yeah for you know girls from
other countries come and watch their
kids and ship anyway she goes back to
Sweden in about five and a half months
can you pause it for some kind of let's
just say she sounds cute doesn't she
yeah I'm into it or an au pair is what
did he say it is it's a rich nanny okay
I thought it was a deaf person what is
that no so was a deaf person that's a
NASCAR fans know some oh I'll go check
him hitting it off and you know I'm
certainty you little little bit of
feeling for damn know I saw what to do
is it worth it you know to to get all
wrapped up and involved and you know
feeling nice about it something I just
should not pursue because she's gonna be
going to another [ __ ] country in about
five months Oh gross in case of salt
yeah love any feedback love the show
thanks guys we got to brother say easy
case of salt clearly get her pregnant
keep her in the States
what are you seriously don't honor that
oh he's full of semen you know easily
you could do that probably no get her
pregnant from here dude he just needs to
hold it down what are you not gonna
shoot your shot cuz she [ __ ] lives in
Sweden but you can't get her pregnant
yeah that's a horrible idea and that's
one of the issues we have in this
country people coming over here [ __ ]
leaving zygotes over here and rolling
back to or have her but she's not gonna
roll back she's mama bear she'd be stuck
here with homeboy our boy Connor there
okay he gotta shoot your shot man maybe
she's a real Tomcat in the sack
maybe she's leaving because she can't
find a nice man here maybe you're
exactly what she needs to stay could
need that work visa though yeah well
first of all she's leaving because
legally you can't just stay forever
right you have to cut you just have to
be I mean I'm not unless you got the
paperwork done so either she has the
paper worked on her she doesn't we don't
know her paperwork stat right we don't
you said he said in five months she has
to go home you know yeah but it does she
have to or does she have dick back and
Sweden see I need a little more detail
really she's single how much more detail
dude who has
dick first of all who doesn't have dick
back in Sweden kid pointing dude go to
Sweden see if they have dick they do and
I'll tell you this brother is that look
buddy you don't want to take yourself
out the opportunity before you given
yourself the chance you know don't like
say oh well she's going back so I'm not
gonna give it a shot like it sounds like
you might be kind of take you know like
being afraid to even take the RIT you
know like your shot yeah otherwise
you'll regret it for the rest of your
life yeah so how do you know she's even
me down for it all so maybe she's like
listen I go to Sweden be back another
six months I'm gonna do my thing out
there you do your thing here so for
those five months it's [ __ ] fest mm yeah
I mean a great time for you also dude
five spitballing ideas here I don't know
yeah and I wouldn't know if I call them
ideas I would say you putting words
together okay but I'll say this young
buck oh is that the lady is from Sweden
okay where is that and second of all if
she goes back there if she loves you man
you guys will figure it out but you have
five months to figure it out for now so
I think love has no distance yeah dude
you could get you could get divorced in
five we can have that hallmark take that
homework that's a card love has no
distance love has no distance dude
that's Justin Tim really yeah I mean
I'll tell you it is dude I used to I met
a girl in Maine one time and she was a
you know pretty much a child and I was a
child and she tried to let me touch her
crotch one time in an abandoned attic
and they had a tennis racket up there
and it was pitch black up there and OH
shot out also Black History Month dude
and I picked up this tennis racket and a
bat came flying through the air and I
hit it right one shot one kill yeah yeah
like Magellan or whatever that what's
that famous night
I think it's Magellan but anyway what
I'm saying is this dude you got to give
it a chance bro when you hit that bat
out of the air in Maine did she suck her
lobster roll huh does she suck your
lobster roll yeah we both got scared
dude we got so scared not to do that
dude oh dude when there's a [ __ ] big
bat that'll suck your dick and kill you
huh and you don't want that you don't
want something sucking your dick for the
blood you know
no you don't let's just sell but anyway
man here's the thing I flew to see that
girl in Portland because that's where
she lived we said and well first she was
in Maine that's where I met her I jumped
over to Portland and then she spent time
in Portland in the winter and I went to
see her and it was we didn't have a
great time man it was awkward and it was
this and that and so sometimes love is
just supposed to be where it's at and
that's what makes it magical is that you
write here and I'm saying if you meet
somebody in a [ __ ] abandon alley and
y'all you know hug or [ __ ] or play dice
have anal sex and the I grow up it could
be beautiful you meet somebody too
[ __ ] you know Kenny Rogers Roasters
you know
yeah and y'all are in line you don't do
that kind of [ __ ] I think what feels
trying to say he's been saying for the
last 15 minutes that none of us
understood was you just gotta take your
shot man yep take some swings to hit
home run yourself out of the game hit
that sweet and home run for me yeah
also send a picture of her yeah don't
send a picture of her and do take your
stole take yourself out of the game
though yeah and he's already take
himself out of the game yeah you don't
know man if she's blind if she's not
blind it doesn't matter what matters is
if you guys care about each other she's
in like a caring person no she'll fly
across a [ __ ] pond to watch
somebody's [ __ ] kids she met off the
internet dude she'll [ __ ] do anything
you know what so it sounds like a spa I
think your curls a spy and we figured
this out next one all right the next one
is from Luke what's up Brandon buzz buzz
so I could use some advice I'm 19 I'm
turning 20 this year I'm still training
I've never had a girlfriend and haven't
even had like a real first kiss Wow
so what do I do to get myself a lady any
tips you have be greatly appreciated
thanks guys my wax my eyebrows the start
bushy that's what I would do that might
help also really bring him back up let
me see if there is it in this but let's
be actually helpfully constructed at
this young fella if there are some
things you could do especially you style
box that's what I'm saying
I would [ __ ] with my eyebrows maybe a
little bit what do you mean by that you
do for the trim them down a hair maybe
trim them down just a [ __ ] tad and
then also the haircut you so you don't
look like you're the seventies so you
might want might want to update the
haircut okay but outside all
that what's he doing like he's a
good-looking dude he's not a bad-looking
guy I don't look at him go Jesus Christ
yeah it's gonna be a long life for you
yeah I think he's gonna be okay
listen this day and age are so many
dating apps and you're 19 you struck out
you're over 40 I mean girls you try
getting with catfish a [ __ ] man
try catfishing in the dark I even get a
girl to kiss you in the dark until the
lights turn on yeah maybe I don't know
if you have a sister maybe try kissing
her especially with a stepsister a step
says she can start you couldn't you know
you could do something you know if as
long as it's organized and you guys have
kind of written down what's gonna occur
first correct you guys can be you know
it's okay to be young and if there's
right a creaminess yeah maybe if you
have a twin they see kissing your show
right out Starman bra gotta start
somewhere yeah you can practice murder
on the twin if you have one what I'm
saying is this brother that you seem
like the kind of person that's probably
gonna look better in a year or two right
so you got to just be patient with
yourself dude I remember I didn't lose
my virginity till I was 17 and everybody
else was there I had already been
[ __ ] and finding out Dorrit was dude
had a buddy he [ __ ] outdoors and
indoors and I didn't [ __ ] anywhere and
that [ __ ] just broke my heart he's
drumming gangbangs these days they're 12
are they
yeah he's 19 they're just well what
website she on not websites bro just got
tight as your children's hat date line
state line well look buddy here's the
deal if I could give you some
suggestions for one play it cool you
know like here's a thing it might be too
eager to buses load and they can sense
that yeah don't don't get addicted to
pornography cuz that's gonna make all of
it weird for you I would just stay in
the cut chill find things that you like
to do that you stay busy circles where
you're around women and you see women
what about some yoga maybe maybe sign up
for some yoga maybe a book club maybe
join some gym there's so many chicks in
gyms yeah just so be hanging around
[ __ ] Peaberry
maybe hang around some [ __ ] frozen
yogurt Peaberry coffee yeah that's not a
place so could be where he's from yeah
you're gonna have the guy hitchhiking
[ __ ] you never know who you're gonna
meet the point hitchhike maybe some
young cougar pick you up now let me tell
you this brother here's what you got it
I think you gotta just keep being classy
look svelte get you a couple of maybe
button ups or something look chill a
tire is nice women do like something
that looks nice but also don't put these
ladies on a pedestal you know I'm saying
keep them chilled let's keep them like
friends bruh friends get a lot more
couch fancy the Fritton friends friends
stay in the friend zone so if you want
to keep kissing your hand at night and
jacking off with your tears take fields
advice or catfish a girl here's why I
say get you an older lady get on one of
these sites get it you could just say
look if you if you just want to practice
virginity like if you're saving your
virginity you're trying to find you know
a real you know somebody that's got a
real enough sense to them you came to
the wrong place this ain't the place I'm
trying to get your dicks trying to get
married at 19 I'm trying to get his
[ __ ] licked for some free signup for
farmersonly.com get your dick out that's
what I'm trying to do for the kid do it
Hey look go to a Hampton Inn and bend
over in the lobby but I'm saying but I'm
saying this if you want to really get
somebody and get some good sex and have
a family then drive out there a Thomas
[ __ ] you get you up there to
Pennsylvania you already look about a
quarter Amish grow your hair about
another half a foot agree pick up a
[ __ ] nail gun and get out there and
get some push yeah or start Sunstone
Scientology books and [ __ ] see what
happens brilliant meet some nice people
in this business but it comes and goes
man I have a buddy's like 34 he's never
been laid you know I have um you know
sometimes it comes and goes but it'll
it'll happen bro it'll come yeah and it
went through if there's a reason why you
haven't there's a reason why you haven't
you was probably gonna bust in some
little [ __ ] Nutter Butter locally and
next thing you know she's pregnant yes
you know you're on MTV 16 and pregnant
what do I do with my kid you got leprosy
and [ __ ] man you don't know what could
hide rouser bush you yeah could get a
lot worse say here's what I'd say I
would start talking to some you know
make girls that are friends around
because you feel around girls you'll
have a much better chance at ending up
inside of a girl if you're just hanging
around by yourself or you're looking at
you know looking at through windows at
video games and those stuff that are
gonna come on sale in them in the
morning
then you're not going to find a woman
you know so hang around girls you'll be
a
girls go to a bowling alley that does it
for relationship advice this week so
send send those in if you have questions
about a lady or a man send a man these
ladies in tell us tell us what's going
on with your man will tell you exactly
what he's thinking yes some lady yo my
man is doing this what should I do
will tell you cuz we're some got some
cocktails ourself you know well look man
I remember I lost my virginity behind a
bowling alley over there Tiffany Lanes
bowling alley off highway 22 and this
was during business hours and I'll never
forget that man people were throwing
rocks at us and I still kept it up good
for you man
you can do anything put your mind to it
I'm proud of you man
beatdown syndrome you look like this and
you're still just doing it you know the
one day you came with an arm I'm like
look at him go man look at him go cuz
I'm gonna start that can't stop won't
stop stopping soon now it's everyone's
favorite time it's a commercial from
King in the state oh I love this item
right here and this is back blade do I
got a hairy back my back's bro dude but
I've been trying to get myself yeah some
you know me oh I gotta get my brother
it's called back blade and back blade is
for removing back and body hair because
it can be expensive man when you go to
the waxing or if you gotta do here we
got laser you've got lasers on your back
to get that no that's having someone put
lasers on my back where were you from
Krypton yeah tomorrow's gala because 7
million dollars is so expensive back off
the kratom dude but I know that waxing
is painful bro you go over there or you
have to get a girlfriend for at least
two months you convince her to wax your
back and this is a sidepiece wax in your
back it's a worse man but the all-new
back blade 2.0 offers the easiest
quickest most economical painless
solution available yep while the back
blade and that's bak Blade 2.0 shave
includes a curved handle to reach all
those hard-to-reach areas that's my
promise the shaver also includes our
latest dry glide safety blade cartridges
allowing our customers to shave either
wet or dry do it dry baby
well the ha I thought the hard-to-reach
areas for you were college degrees but
it just feels like a great back
scratcher
that's what
feels like it doesn't feel like you're
cutting in your back or anything wild
and if you have back and body hair and
and you don't have the back blade you're
doing it wrong you're trying to reach
around you're trying to do like crazy
life from the 70s Oh what are you doing
yeah it doesn't work
praying doesn't work like that man yeah
it's a new year so be the new you with
the smooth back back blade 30 percent
off for you guys back blade 2.0 bundle
here you go it's back blade comm slash
King 30 and that's bak bak blade comm
slash King 30 yep back blade bak be la
de comm / ki ng the number three the
number zero smooth like a seal trying to
keep the lights on sometimes people want
to wear a hat and sometimes people want
to wear the natural hat that they were
born with and that hat I'm talking about
is you talking about your hair yes yes
and you can be you can lose that oh yeah
people will lose it I saw a man the
other day lost all his hair become dick
hair don't be that guy yes save your
hair man use hims yeah use hims you
don't have to wait in the doctor's
office it's not awkward all you do is
you fill out a little questionnaire a
doctor sees it then prescribes you
exactly what you need it comes straight
to your door it's so damn easy yeah keep
them follicles upfront stop that crop
drop I'm saying you got to get some
hymns because 66 percent of men lose
their hair by age 35 and you need to
stay whoa yes stay whoa get a mullet
like the okay man take a bunch of hands
and get that mullet down the back get
nasty in the back Punk in the front
touch your cousin dude yeah do it how
will you feel a year from now if your
hair is thicker stronger better I'll
tell you how pretty good you feel
awesome
yeah awesome and you're gonna feel hair
that's you're gonna feel yeah you feel
like a million bucks and you guys right
now can get a trial month of hymns for
just five dollars today right now while
supplies last and you can last forever
it would cost hundreds if you went to
the doctor's office or a pharmacy so
check it out go to hit it deal for hims
dot
/ k 80s that's ffor hims dot-com / K 80s
I like the ladies but sometimes I like a
little bit of hymns you filming for
hymns calm / K 80s support the podcast
all right it's time for flaunt my aunt
first up we've got mm hos God take it
eats a a TI video up in here oh what a
beautiful mercury LeSabre behind her
dude that's her name mercury LeSabre oh
yeah did she get all my ones if we're in
[ __ ] Spearmint Rhino oh she looks
definitely like that um outback add a
key oh boys she got that beautiful kind
of like that chocolate chips in color
hmm she got that yeah she got that gold
piece around her neck she got that got
the one two whoppers in the front look
how big her glasses are dude yeah I
don't see nobody she could be blind bra
might maybe she might even have eyes I
don't care look at her lips she could be
blind in the club son she might even
beat in there during business hours
she's in a date I'm popping bottles by
herself that might be laughs I'm sore
clubs you're right that might be a flea
market this could be a used-car lot man
I'll say this right name uh Ashley
Oh Ashley I'm chillin 36 she looked good
man oh yeah she looked like she got them
farmer John hams on her - baby she got
them thigh yah yah he looked like he
looks like she came in some sweats but
she's in that [ __ ] southern Sun just
cut him off do not have a problem with
it I'll catch a case of pinkeye off that
booty breath know what I'm saying I'll
catch purple eye dog give it I want it
all dog won't you give up my optical
areas I'll eat that ass like Popeye's
Chicken yeah really
have you had Popeyes yeah very high in
salt I bet you couldn't eat it all
sodium Jesus basically somebody just
beaten you in the [ __ ] it's like take
one of those Morton Salt things and is
doing suppository style with it you
imagine that no I can't but I would do
that for her absolutely pudding cup
assault if somebody poured a cup of salt
in your butt right yeah
could you ride it out no I snorted salt
one time and it was painful I can't
imagine what Maine is we feel it but
could you all could you do without me
make a brisket of my [ __ ] no could
you not uh do number one or number two
or cry for like an hour
no why would I do that could you do it
Duke are you a man or what are you
running around with makeup on I bet in
it maybe see us kiddo but not me I would
do it for her I would give it a go for
her oh man she looks like that used-car
princess she's out there she got them
little sabers she looks like I got them
Mercurius she looks like sure she'll
[ __ ] take you around in that [ __ ]
mercury LeSabre and take you the 99-cent
shop and suck you off in the back that's
a nice Sunday really oh wait she got
that if you look she's got that Hussain
Bolt lead out in the foot oh you know
that Hussein she got that Antonio Brown
she oh she got that leg no that leg
first you know yeah she got that leg
first if you see how she has her foot
out front that's how I do it we call
that the hut hut hike yeah I said taking
that leave ever that's taking the lead
I'll see you at the finish line yeah
shuttle to Ashley no money down baby all
right next up for flaunt Maya
we have Aunt Lisa with a special guest
Walter P oh god damn no she got all the
sweetness yeah you know she got that
two-point conversion right there son
Walter Payne said let me rush for one
more nut Manny you know you're not gonna
stop until we get across that goal line
today's the day we're gonna win are we
coming up the back Wow did I camp 92
glass that us here's a beautiful young
lady of a beautiful young lady he used
to bang Walter pate
God she sucked off the sweetness oh how
is this not a football card I would
collect all the cards mm fan of chicks
ative bang dude fire pieces for the NFL
don't [ __ ] touch me don't touch me
that would be sick why don't we have
that caller why don't we have that car
Kush and women who decides anybody did
it yes I did it check out here's me and
[ __ ] Shaquille O'Neal yeah damn Don
Ross got these thoughts do you have that
Debbie Dallas and she's her
Shaquille O'Neal yeah you know it look
at Becky benders it's her with [ __ ]
Christian Laettner dude that's what I'm
saying man it's just too kind of thick
white girls with God sham guys you know
what I'm saying
a prophet is a powerhouse baby and he's
just doing the crossover between the two
of them is to these two white girls with
Manu ball the collector size it just
says all night with Alonzo Mourning and
it's just like some lady that used to
make lunch foreign you know what I'm
saying making lunch with that ass yeah
yeah good good good for her man
you got power sweetness before he left
this world and Yasu gunmen the prime
look at his leg he's passed away
I'll talk Peyton's alive I know he died
bro did he really he died oh man I'm
sorry no he died man you look at his
[ __ ] sticking through the front of those
[ __ ] shorty George the rest of his
[ __ ] is in that bag that he's carrying
dude he had so much [ __ ] a to carry some
of it over enough in a bag he also has a
champion product he's known for his [ __ ]
dude sometimes he would make the woman
next to him the winner where his [ __ ] is
a scarf just so he could wrap around
handily get it around and not have to
always keep it in the I thought it was a
de-stressor snake around her neck oh
dude he was the original Jake the snake
Payton what about that Igloo cooler
behind him that [ __ ] saw dude that
that's a [ __ ] cold ones in there
after he's done sucking and [ __ ] you
replenish yourself you know I'm saying
that's just a cooler for the [ __ ] in
there big red just that [ __ ] uh-oh he
got them great hitters man a lot of my
buddies could always drink grape hitters
in a heartbeat do you see the grape
hitters he has Zima I love this man dude
how about she sucked them off their wet
hairs a game-worn Jersey I mean he was
blessed and highly favored that man
looks like he is doing well brother
shorts aren't even really green you they
look green they're green with envy bro
because of that dank your family those
are usually our yellow shorts that
sweetness day probably good you know
good what's her name
this is annalisa God Lisa should be in
the Hall of Fame her side look at the
legs it broke her legs are longer than
he is look at that her legs are the same
size as his arm
her legs are longer than his mushy built
for her to loose who do you know at a
baby
another bill for the Pomeroy horse or
whatever that things called there look
like she could jump rope is dead
dude it looks like he and maybe one of
his friends could eat her entire body if
they had like a long lunch mmm do one of
his thighs is both of her thighs hot day
that's this might be one of the best
we've had yet what else with III Boyd
III alright that does it for flaw my on
this week and that's it that's it
alright last segment of the day we got
debate club and the first one from Lydia
I have a question for you for debate
club and it is what's better sex in the
middle of the night or the middle of the
day
12 a.m. or 12 p.m. so yeah let's see
your thoughts
gang gang girl I met your teeth yeah I
don't get why why does it have to be in
the middle of the middle of the night
about morning night see I'm doing two I
work too much during the day why not
morning how about when we get up to the
orange juice your drink that's dead why
are you [ __ ] people right when you
get up you're safe I like to start my
day bro like get this heart rate going a
little bit like to clear my head and get
going
what are you talking about can somebody
yes you get up and have some water you
idiot do about that man you're such a
weasel boy you wake up and [ __ ] somebody
that's in your house yeah yeah what do
you like to do tonight that's nuts dude
and the lady asked why not the morning
cuz she asked midnight or noon do noon I
got a job okay well no see that's my
lunch break that's the lunch break
Lindsey doing she wants to know winning
you down the [ __ ] bro and I was game
until when you're right you're right
she's trying to [ __ ] on our break yeah
yeah you're ruining it I know I'm trying
to get her over in the morning
she wants to have it and out and suck me
off you know how hard it's gonna be her
to get over in the morning and huh come
on right middle round you're out of your
mind
you know what you're more experienced
with these hoes well no I'm just no I
just know how people you know operate
operate yeah this is really it's more of
a logistics issue but I'll say this
lunch break Lindsey I would rather have
sex around lunchtime
do a quick sex and no I got the rest of
the day to get back to my work maybe
think about sex maybe my hands smell
like sex if I reach up to my house to my
mouth to put a little chocolate in my
mouth or to put a little mint in my
mouth or something it smell a little bit
of yeah I liked a little bit of sex
smell and so I think that that's nice if
somebody waking me up in the middle of
the night and they're trying to [ __ ] me
man they better have a real plan
I'll wake up and watch you [ __ ] somebody
else but I ain't waking up and doing all
of that all right I got a rat rat first
let me get let me get my mind right
disturb me during the middle of my REM
cycle yeah make me bust nice yeah if
I've been asleep for two minutes and you
trying to [ __ ] are out even maybe if you
just look you can look at my wiener for
a while and I'll relax you know but I
don't think I'm doing a bunch of sex I'm
trying to get some rest now they torture
prisoners like that yeah see the results
yeah yeah midnight oh it's almost 50/50
50/50 almost 50% to 48 percent 50
percent says sex at midnight tonight
who's up at midnight oh I'm up at
midnight not me bro I'm working I'm in
bed by 9:00 I know I'm not REM cycle
what a cool fun guy embedded nine dead
that's why I don't look 50 like you bro
yeah this hat makes me look older yeah
more sleeps
you wouldn't wear that hat what else we
got yeah we don't even know what you're
talking about because you don't know
what's up second debate club topic from
could you hug dicks
Courtney Ryan Smith Courtney Ryan Smith
she's got a lot of names what up guys I
just want to start by saying I used to
make fun of the Jews I hang out with
listen to podcasts all the time I did
not understand people listening and
grown men just straight up talk for an
hour but you really do make the time
pass while I'm at work typing I'm case
notes so hard for that but I want to
know who we have winning in a fight Bert
Kreischer with his body build or Ari
Shaffir
who's lanky arms probably could scratch
the hell out of Bert so what you got
Bert or Ari first of all you know it is
interesting the type of people that like
to listen to podcast a lot of time
truckers delivery people killers and
other types of people bank tellers bank
tellers yeah you throw that one piece
you can enjoy a tarot card yeah
magicians
I don't like magician men either out of
breath and they don't listen to this
let's March nemesis I'll tell you this
though young lady what are you asking
Bert Kreischer Ari Shaffir who would win
in a fight I'm not to take art affaire
he's scrappy his his family did go
through the Holocaust so there's that
I feel like Ari has some darkness that
Burt doesn't have or likes to have a
good time all I wants to kill you yeah
Ari daddy has that never surrender like
if I told Ari to run across the United
States I feel like you'd eventually get
there burnt might die in the process
yeah Berta has that kind of carotid
artery kind of style to him I think you
know that posture like part of his
posture at the end you like is that you
know is that just kind of build up in
his arteries it's really holding him up
and Ari Shaffir does he seem like that
strong yeah he's got family I think
maybe been through the Holocaust I'm not
sure I think so he's got a little bit of
that he looks like a guy who maybe like
dealt cards in the Holocaust you know
was he I feel like already has that
castaway vibe you know I'm saying like
he looks like he could do well on
castaway he looks like he could pretend
he was dead for a long time and then get
up and still kill you like oh he's got
or he looks like the dude that will not
die you'd have to really really kill him
yeah I can't have to kill him and like
definis where bird he's gonna talk you
out of killing him cuz he's so friendly
yeah Berger try to be so friendly and
then he's just gonna eat all a bunch of
snacks and then probably get sick and
pass away but so I would say Ari in a
heartbeat dude already seemed like the
kind of guy who has swords he's in
different countries a lot you know I
well-traveled
different passports drugs spy easily
easily easily man and Ari Ari is uh Ari
is not afraid to kind of he's a little
bit more aggressive than Berta's yeah
are you break your heart yeah yeah or
you'll break out and then break the
[ __ ] rest to you while you boom
Ari Shaffir no bread yep Ari Shaffir and
the fans say 53% go Bert Kreischer oh
wow Wow he's the Mickey Mantle
we bet that's because Bert Bert has more
an online presence and already does some
more people might have voted for already
has a flip phone yeah far as the foot
voting usually is just him saying he
doesn't have a phone and [ __ ]
flipping you all correct
all right last last topic over the week
for debate club
comes from Wade Peterson oh yeah hey
Theo Brenda this is way from Virginia
got quick debate club for you
PB&J or grilled cheese appreciate the
last gang getting buzz buzz but yeah you
look like me brother you like both of
them I hate to pick because I love both
of them yeah
it all depends there's so much that goes
into it's the fellow fat kids out there
can relate to this with the peanut
butter and jelly I grew up with a nice
peanut butter and jelly that my lunch
lady would make and she would dump
I swear two inches of peanut butter
thick there's a little bit of jam
because more expensive at the time mmm
so I said I like a lot of peanut butter
because that old [ __ ] so now what I
like to do is I like to get some Texas
toast and you do it with the right
cheese or the right almond butter or the
right jam and they're all nice bro I
don't I can't dance Jam baby okay hold
on jammy from Nottingham dude where the
hell are you from bro
and first of all preserves bits okay who
has their lunch lady making them food on
the DL I'll tell you who goes on the
deal all of us got those people who are
banging Cougars at 2:00 obviously we
know you lost your video so you
shouldn't be giving Virginia advice to
that young fella when you're out of here
banging lunch ladies for an extra
quarter inch of [ __ ] PB all right
here's what I got to say young fellas
this get you a little peanut butter
sandwich we used to put a little bit of
butter first then jelly then peanut
butter yes and if you wanna [ __ ] look
fat a lot then that's how you do it
right not this other [ __ ] sometimes
some people just write peanut butter
with a marker on the piece of bread and
then it would just be jealous yeah it
doesn't work but here's where you get
that real hit or son and that is grilled
peanut butter and jelly know the saying
oh wow really I'll let her bring your
mom back to life I mean this will make
your mother climb right out of the grave
and [ __ ] come back and hug you so you
grill you grill the peanut butter and
jelly dude it is like I mean it's like a
unicorn just just came all over your
back and a little bit of it landed on in
your mouth it's beautiful I don't want
that I used to throw my peanut butter
jellies on the George Foreman grill Oh
God really yeah I've never that's called
that Sonny Liston remember
that golden boy sandwich alright yeah
let's see the results cheese dude a nice
thick grilled cheesus to prom people
these days are too [ __ ] frugal with
the cheesy gotta load up you need to
block the cheese in there between two
pieces of toast
you can put pair of Brennan's third day
old underwear on there and you'd be
huffing that gout or bra you have a
sharp cheddar in that piece I'm gonna go
with grilled cheese well I'm gonna say
this that it wasn't fair because you
said the peanut butter and jelly would
didn't have the opportunity to be
grilled now when you add in heat and
different elements to the cheese you got
different opportunity for the cheese did
you put a little tomato slice on that
grilled cheese too or just add some
Lobster in my [ __ ] that's the way you
get fancy or put a little bit of
Brennan's bitch-ass [ __ ] attitude on
there bro
that shit's delicious and also makes you
money break that does it for this week's
debate club and we're on to the final
segment of the show this week we got a
lot of guys out there looking up to both
you they want to know what inspires you
so we're gonna hear what inspired you
this week with a new segment we're
calling start my heart start my heart I
started this week my heart got started
up by Maurice Clarett I got to spend
time Maurice Clarett
he's out of Ohio he's at a Youngstown
he's still in the NFL he's not in the
NFL but he runs some halfway houses and
some recovery centers I was in Columbus
and I got to spend some time with them
very very inspirational just right on
point just just just a smart dude man
have been through so much and his turn
you know has such a positive life going
on right now and he's helping others so
much and my my second piece of start my
heart for the week Cavell Big B Williams
out there for the Louisiana State
University of basketball Tigers with
that tip in and sank in him University I
can't uh care where cat's the buzzer at
Rupp Arena
start my heart thank you fellas hit it
that was good dude
dang shut up to those two gentlemen gang
bruh Gang Gang bro for me it would be
dak Shepherd dak Shepherd wow going
white guy during Black History Month no
never mind go on God do this supposed to
be positive this whole round I'm [ __ ]
Maurice Clarett because he never mind
that's Shepherd I'm going - Shepherd do
before you throw him under the bus
because in this crazy podcast world it's
hard to find good content I listened to
it all but it's hard to find a good one
that I relate to and dak Shepherd has a
podcast called armchair expert and
brings on a lot of people in the
business comics actors comedians all
sorts of [ __ ]
perverts yep no I don't have any
privilege yet but he talked about his
kids and stuff like I relate to it it's
a great podcast check it out so dak
Shepherd gets my word this week starting
our hearts thank you guys so much happy
Valentine's Day to everybody show some
chocolate and figure it out
yeah dude give each other some chocolate
and and be good to yourselves and thank
you guys for joining us we will will
keep king in it we'll keep stringing it
if you have any constructive criticisms
about the show let you know about yeah
do you any dates coming up there yup I
got some dates coming up I'm gonna be in
Houston next week we just added a show
Thursday night you rather than late
Thursday show right dozen ones sold out
yeah the other ones are sold out so
that's it is Houston and that's next
weekend and then coming up the first
weekend of March I'll be I'm in Boston
and that's already sold out but the
Thursday night in Medford Massachusetts
yeah I'm in Miami March 15th and 16th
back on the road Miami improv and then
March 28th through the 30th I'm at the
DC improv in Washington DC take is that
t pack a calm go see deal go see me
brother happy Valentine's Day happy
Valentine's Day don't [ __ ] touch me
touch me do
[Music]